ask you a question like do you know how
you broke through and made such a sort
of space for yourself
I think when I have the ability to be
impressionable to seven million plus
people whether it's on Peloton or
Netflix I think it is important for me
to have that wide range right that entry
point whether it's the music whether
it's my words whether how I dress how I
sound and to be completely transparent
to answer your question I think of if my
grandmom was watching or when she is
watching would she love it right and
that to me is like that's how I live my
life that is my entry point that is my
next step that is the next level for me
is that if I sit here with Drew will my
grandma say wow she made it and she will
foreign
[Applause]
on Instagram you show Post-it notes with
positive affirmations I love that I do
that too and so
um I we wrote a note for each other I
think
[Applause]
I say to writing ourselves good
affirmations but there are things that
other people can see and say that we
cannot do for ourselves so I think those
are equally as meaningful okay okay
oh Ali says if possible was a person it
would be you Jesus this is amazing
I don't know if that's motivating it's
sure humbling it's true thank you you
make a lot of things possible we've see
I mean a lot of us have followed your
career and as women who look at other
women you are one of those women I
literally I'm checking for you all the
time my husband has watched your like
Blended movie like 90 times he's
probably gonna like cringe saying this
like we've watched your career and when
I think of aspirational women that I
look up to and that I'm like what are
they they're doing you've been a great
representation in terms of our community
so I want to say thank you it's true if
possible
lead
[Music]
[Applause]
you have multiple I love it amazing
Endeavors going on and you are a leader
so
thank you
now because I'm like on the Alley love
feeder well you do one of my favorite
things with me which is three to go it's
suggestions you will give us of things
we can take away okay
wow
[Applause]
all right Ellie okay so many people
follow you who should we follow okay
um I recently started following Kelsey
ballerini I saw her at the Papo show and
a friend of mine is a friend of hers and
they're like she's an amazing person and
a great human and I play her music in my
class and I know she had gone through
like a situation and she's like she's on
her glow up phase and I want to be a
part of that in terms of being a witness
to it and I think that is why I started
following her I think her content is
inspiring I think her music is great so
she is a new person for me that I
started following that I think is like
truly amazing I followed her too so I
really appreciate what you said
all right
what song makes you move that we could
all go Shake our butts too oh Shake our
butts Shake our bonbons I mean you put
any Beyonce song It's a Rap I can't hear
you I'm
out and so for me it's like I feel good
in my bon bons there okay good yeah get
that lavender Haze rocking okay what's
making you laugh
what's making me laugh is this is gonna
sound again myself and let me tell you
don't don't judge me don't judge me I'm
intrigued I'm not a funny person like
I'm I'm literally in the friend group
everyone laughs because they feel bad at
me because I'm like I tell a joke and I
tell the punchline before and I'm like
wait wait let me do it again like I'm
that person okay so at home I've been
practicing like voices so I like
literally crack myself up because I wake
up and I'm like oh what are we doing for
dinner today my husband's like okay
what's going on I'm like I said what are
we doing like are we going and I am just
all over the place at home because I'm
working on just like you know being
comfortable in myself so make yourself
laugh I am making myself laugh all right
I am I like it
is streaming now on Netflix
[Music]